salut bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nos sur rt france alors selon vous
va t'on assisté un effet qu vide
les français vont-ils être nombreux à
vouloir se faire vacciner
bonjour oui j'espère j'espère
effectivement que les français sont
nombreux
c'était au moins toutes les personnes
qui trêve devait signer se faire
vacciner et en particulier les sujets de
65 ans et plus pour qui la vaccination
en france et gratuit et l'on gagne et
atom simple pour sa ces personnes
avaient été vaccinées mais j'espère que
cette année
effectivement le tour chantal sera
beaucoup plus élevé
allez-y chose entrer pourquoi est-ce que
bien sûr il pouvait leur concomitance du
public avec les limites
il est évident que la vaccination
grippale ou 3h pas contre la crise on
entend que poivey question évidemment
que non ce sont deux virus totalement
différent et donc le vaccin grippe ne
protège pas contre la grippe mais il
demande une protection contre la grippe
et comme les cinq hommes qui ne peuvent
être quelquefois les mêmes même souvent
sadrau sa table et on évitera ainsi de
personnes qui rompt un ferme et
audacieux car chaque année beaucoup de
sujets crétins formes graves qui
nécessitent des hospitalisations qui
viendrait donc le service de réa qu'il
faut garder pour la corse alors
justement on l'a dit au début de ce
journal pour la première fois depuis le
mois de mai plus de 1500 personnes
atteinte du coville 19 aujourd'hui en
service de réanimation prioriser les
personnes qui vont se faire vacciner
c'est la bonne stratégie pour éviter un
engorgement des hôpitaux
oui oui c'est la bonne stratégie c'est
celle de la stratégie habituelle je
répète depuis des années la vaccination
est recommandée et gratuite pour ces
sujets il nous est tous bien fait de
cette vaccination
donc cette année pour les raisons que je
viens de donner c'est évidemment la
bonne stratégie
il faut donc encourager plus
d'encourager vraiment insister sur le
fait toutes les personnes qui vont
recevoir qui reçoivent tous reçu dès
aujourd'hui le rebond pour la
vaccination se fasse vacciner
il n'y a pas de les personnes de 65 ans
et plus d'ailleurs il ya aussi toutes
les personnes qui présentent des
affections de longue durée diabète
d'insuffisance cardiaque sont tous les
sujets à risque doivent donc se faire
vacciner en priorité et bien sûr 3,3 tu
as de quoi le personnel de santé qui
doivent être vaccinés contre la grippe
car là aussi il y a un déficit chaque
animal heureusement mais c'est à dire
non enfin ils se fassent vacciner alors
on sait que la campagne de vaccination
va se poursuivre jusqu'au 31 janvier le
gouvernement a commandé un peu plus de
15 millions et demi de minots et demi au
oui de 12 l'année dernière environ 11
millions est ce qu'il y a tout de même
un risque de pénurie cette année selon
vous ça fait des fichiers la ville se
trouvant tout précipite sur la
vaccination boudées les sujets qui ne
sont pas les sujets prioritaires que je
viens cité et si tu tournes dessous se
précipitaient sur la vaccination
on risque le fait d'avoir effectivement
une ville vaccins un don c'est pas pour
ça il fait la logique c'est tôt les
personnes à risque se fassent vacciner
très très rapidement en début de
campagne puis ensuite on verra si ray
des stocks de vaccins
dernière question nous sommes en plein
milieu de crise concernant justement le
locaux vides 19 on a plus que déjà des
gestes barrières le lavage des mains
mais également le port du masque est ce
que voilà ces mêmes gestes peuvent nous
aider à minimiser la grippe saisonnière
oui oui c'est une maladie la transition
respiratoires bien sûr le virus circule
tellement un sentiment qu'on incite
évidemment sur les mesures barrières les
ces mesures barrières sont valables pour
toute maladie à transmission
respiratoires et donc évidemment ça peut
déjà également contre la circulation des
galets du clipon quand ils commenceront
à circuler
oui très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
pierre salou d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur agrégé au val de grâce